okay let's solve leak code 198 house
robber in my opinion this is such a good
question to understand even though it's
just an easy question you can learn so
much about dynamic programming from this
problem and you might already know
Google really loves asking dynamic
programming problems and if you want to
get started on that this is such a good
question to understand
so we're basically given an array of
integers like many problems and each
integer represents a house right so this
is a house this is a house this is a
house they're all houses and they're
adjacent to each other so it's basically
a neighborhood we want to rob houses to
maximize the amount of money we can rob
so why not just rob all of them right
nope there's a restriction we can't rob
two houses that are adjacent to each
other so we can rob this house but then
we can't rob this house right so we have
to rob this one next maybe right on the
other hand if we rob this one we can't
rob this one and we can't rob this one
it has two neighbors this might sound
really difficult right so let's just
start out with the brute force approach
let's imagine if we were trying to get
every single combination okay so the
first combination is where we pick the
first house right so let's draw out what
the decision tree of that would look
like okay so our first decision was to
rob the house with value one okay so
next we want to rob more houses right
but we can't rob this one so we can we
have to basically get the max we can Rob
from these two so does that sound kind
of like a sub problem yeah but we'll get
there in a minute so continuing on with
just a brute-force right okay so now we
want to rob these two houses right well
we can't rob both of them because
they're right next to each other so we
can either rob house 3 or we can rob
house 1 so this is the decision tree
right and so along this path so if we
were to rob house 1 right let's say we
went along this path then we can either
rob house 1 and 3 or we can rob house 1
and 1 obviously we're gonna choose this
one because that gives us the total that
gives us the maximum which is 4 okay but
what if we didn't Rob the first house we
decided to rob the second
so that would be our other decision in
our decision tree right Rob house - okay
now we have not many choices right we
can't Rob house three so the only house
left is house one so we rob that one as
well
so if we went along this pathway in our
decision tree we would get these two
houses robbed and that's a total of
three but we remember we found this
which was a total of four which is
greater of course so that's going to be
our result now this is a very
brute-force approach imagine if we had
more numbers here right maybe a three
and a four then we'd have to have like
more paths in our decision tree this
could get very complex so how can we
improve it can we identify any
subproblem and the answer to that is yes
let's take a look at the subproblem so
remember we have two choices we want to
get the max that we can rob from this
entire neighborhood so the first choice
is we rob from the first house and then
find the maximum from the remaining
houses right imagine there's more houses
here there could be a three or four
whatever right this is the subproblem
we're finding the max of a sub array of
the entire array the second choice we
have is we skip this house right if we
skip it then basically we're saying okay
find the maximum of the entire sub array
not including the first value so let's
actually write out the relationship if
it doesn't make sense yet so if we want
to find the max we can Rob from the
entire array we have two choices Rob in
this case indicates the max that we can
Rob from the entire array so in our
first decision we decided that we were
gonna Rob the first value so array of
index 0 plus Rob the remainder of this
blue portion of the array so we're
skipping index 1 we're gonna Rob the
entire array from index 2 to the end so
I'll say n is the end in this case so
that's our first decision if we decided
to rob the first house then we're gonna
break up the problem into a sub problem
now we got to Rob the remainder of that
array
skipping one of the values if we didn't
rob the first house and then we simply
only have the sub-problem robbed every
house skipping the first house so we
start at house one not house zero and go
until the end of the array so this is
the recurrence relationship you might
not know exactly what that means but
it's basically a way to break up dynamic
programming problems notice the result
of the entire problem depends on only
these two if we can compute these two
then we have our result
but notice each Rob can be broken up
into its own sub-problem just like we
did over here so let's actually solve
the subproblems now before we solve the
entire problem now I could do this in
reverse order right I could say let's
find the max of this sub array this sub
array and so on but it's a little more
confusing to do that so I'm actually
going to do it in order so let's start
at the first house like we've been doing
so if we rob this house that's basically
our base case right so we can decide to
rob this house in that case up until
this point we could Rob a total of 1 ok
now we get to the second house so what's
the max we can Rob up until this point
well we can decide to not rob this house
and only rob this house if we wanted to
or we can decide to not rob this house
and only rob this house to is obviously
greater than 1 so I'm gonna decide only
to rob this house next we get to house 3
this is where it gets interesting so
what's the max amount we can Rob up
until this point so we have two choices
again we can Rob house 3 and we can Rob
house 1 or we can just Rob house to the
max is obviously if we Rob house 3 and 1
and in that case we'd get a total of 4
now we get to the last value 1 so we can
decide to Rob house 1 and if we did Rob
house 1 then we would want the max we
could Rob up until these two values
meaning we'd want 1 plus 2 because 2
tells us what's the max we can Rob from
these first two elements we
include this one because it's adjacent
to one so one of our choices is one plus
two that's choice one or we can decide
to not even Rob house one we can just
get the max of the entire first three
elements not including this one in that
case we have what we would get from the
first three elements right here we
already computed it it's four so our
choices are one plus two or four
obviously four is greater so I'm gonna
choose four that means we put a four
right here and this for this last four
means that for the entire array the
entire array the max value we could get
is four if we wanted to rob houses so we
can put a 4 here but notice how we don't
have to look we don't even have to store
this entire blue portion for each value
like for this one for to compute this we
only need to look at the previous two
results that we computed and the reason
for that is because we could either
decide to rob this one and Rob the
remainder portion of the array not
including 3 and in which case we'd have
the value computed right here the other
cases if we wanted the max we could Rob
from the entire array we could decide to
not even include this and just get the
max from these three and in that case
the value would be stored here so now
let's look at the code since we only
need to maintain the last two maxes that
we could rob from we'll only need two
variables so I'll just name them Rob 1
Rob 2 we'll initialize them as zero
because if we get an empty sub-array we
want to return zero anyway so let's
iterate through each of the houses we
can Rob and now we want to compute the
maximum that we can Rob up and tell this
value n so I'm gonna compute that in a
temporary variable for now and you'll
probably see why so the max we can Rob
up until now in my case I'm gonna say
Rob 1 or Rob 2 was the last house that
we robbed
Rob one was the one before
that so knowing that the max we could
get would be n+ Rob one meaning there's
a gap between the current house and the
previous house or Rob two which includes
the previous house in case it's not
clear this is basically let me just make
a comment to show what I mean by Rob 1
and Rob - so Rob 1 is first
Rob 2 comes second and then we get some
more values and n plus 1 and so on so if
I want a Rob n then I have to Rob Rob
one as well I can't use Rob 2
but if I want to do Rob - I can include
n because it's right next to it so when
we iterate to the next position meaning
we get here we want to update Rob one to
now equal Rob - so let's do that
and Rob 2 in this case wants to be
updated to n so Rob 2 can now equal our
temporary value that we just computed at
the end we want to return Rob 2 because
by the time we get to the end Rob 2 will
be equal to the last value meaning that
it will be the max we can rob from the
entire neighborhood of houses this is a
problem you can learn so much from even
though it's an easy problem it might
take you a while to digest exactly
what's going on and to understand all
the like importance of this problem so
many dynamic program programming
problems are built upon this one and let
me know if you have any questions
because I feel like I might not have
explained like the recurrence
relationship quite well enough but if
this was helpful thank you for watching
leave a like and subscribe and let me
know if you have any suggestions